and our crazy upset that Monell is no
longer going to be on Supergirl it's
forcing the fandom to give up their
hopes of the caramel ship ever actually
happening so as a tribute to one of the
most complicated love stories in the DC
universe we're putting together a list
of Cara and Mon Al's most romantic
moments I know what it's like to be a
stranger on this planet mo now first
appeared on Supergirl at the beginning
of the second season mo now finally saw
the mystery of what was in the pod you
know the pod that crash-landed in the
season 1 finale
well when Mon L woke up from his pod
coma and met Supergirl for the first
time let's just say it wasn't love at
first sight now we all know that Monell
is actually the prince of daksa m-- an
enemy planet of Krypton that explains
the whole choking thing during their
first introduction so Monell kept his
identity a secret that is until his
cover was blown when his mom and dad
came to earth looking for him no now did
wind up helping Supergirl save the earth
from being destroyed by his mother but
because the planet was now uninhabitable
for all daksa mites including moe now he
had to take off to space then he got
sucked into a wormhole and time jumped
to a distant future there he was very
busy getting married and forming the
Legion of super-heroes
before coming back to fight rain and the
world killers car was devastated that
monel married someone else but it's
clear he still had feelings for Cara
that is one complicated relationship
nevertheless fans were shipping Cara and
Monell hard giving them the couple named
caramel let's just say fans aren't
taking this character's departure from
the show very well so to bandage the
pain of our loss let's reminisce
together about the good times they had
she's his kryptonite the Valentine's Day
episode of season 2 started out pretty
rough for Cara but things really turned
around after Supergirl defeated masseur
masseuse Catholic Monell shows up at
Cara's apartment to tell her how awesome
she is super sweet and adorable he
commends her on out tricking the most
cunning intergalactic trickster he goes
on to say that she did it her way
without violence then he apologizes to
her for acting like a jerk and then he
drops the ultimate superhero romance
line of all time and I have realized
that you are my kryptonite and all the
fans everywhere side and
wound in unison MOU now continues saying
he's never felt this way about anyone
he basically admits that he's crazy in
love with her then Carr admits that she
tricked him when she said they didn't
belong together she said she told him
that to protect him he comes in closer
and says I think stalking us then they
finally break that monumental tension
between them by engaging in a steamy
kiss wowsa
fans agreed that moment was without a
doubt totally worth the wait
but that wasn't technically their first
kiss remember earlier in the season when
Mona got that Medusa virus he was kind
of out of it and pretty sure who's going
to die but when cara visits him he sits
up in bed
he tells kar how beautiful she is and
plants a soft kiss on her lips then he
passes out again
well cara thought he didn't remember the
kiss that is until later when he
confesses to her that he did remember
kissing her he said he remembers that he
was sick and alone and that she was
leaning over him
Monell said that he thought she may have
been sad because her eyes were insanely
blue you guys he said her eyes looked
like comets that is like the most
romantic compliment ever
but Monell doesn't stop there he said he
had never seen anyone so stunning and
then afterwards he thought it was okay
that he was going to die because he got
to kiss her and that's when our TV
melted he capped the necklace we know
how important Cara's necklace was to her
her mother gave it to her before sending
her away from her dying planet krypton
car almost never took that necklace off
and wore it into her adulthood but when
Mona was leaving Earth Cara gave that
necklace to him so he would always
remember her one of the sweetest scenes
between the couple is when kar realizes
that monel kept the necklace even after
all that time in the future he said he
kept the necklace as a reminder of
everything she did for him and taught
him he said he held on to it because it
reminded him of her car is holding back
tears when she says how much that means
to her Monell assures Cara that no
matter what century or universe or world
he's living in she would never forget
her the garden scene there's that
gorgeous scene in the garden with Mona
and Cara toward the end of season 3 Cara
is strolling through the garden in that
flowing white gown and Monell joins her
it's so perfectly matched the dream she
had in the season premiere car shares
that she is not cut out for the kind of
happiness that Dhara has
she says she is happy that Monell is
there cartels bonell but his friendship
has made the whole journey a lot easier
she thanks him and hugs him then Monell
confesses that he didn't just come back
to help her fight rain he says that he
also came back to sort out how he felt
about Cara he says he thinks he has been
lying to himself that he's not so sure
that friendship is the right thing for
them
cartels monel about the dream she tells
him that all she wanted was to have him
there with her and now here he is she
puts her hand on his cheek and for a
moment everything seems right with all
the worlds so why does Monell have to go
away fans are super bummed
however the producer said that they only
planned on having him for a couple of
seasons the show's executive producer
Jessica Quiller said that car and Monell
both have destinies that take place on
different timelines they decided on the
sword of Casablancas ending character
had to put the thing that was most
important to them above anything else
they have to save the world but once
destiny is to be a hero in this time and
the others destiny is to run the Legion
in another time koala went on to say
that she thinks they grew a lot from
knowing one another they have respect
for each other and they also have
respect for the decisions they both had
to make what was your favorite romantic
moment between Cara and Monell how do
you feel about these going their
separate ways let us know in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
of these moments had you shipping Carmel
all over again be sure to subscribe to
the things and don't forget to hit that
notification bell while you're at it
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]